and we are in live streaming so
like to welcome joining us on live
streaming
right welcome to the infrastructure
services committee meeting
march 2nd 2021.
um i have uh one apology and that is
from councillor amundsen
and we have two zoo members council
rabbit
and councillor arnold so can i
please have someone move we accept
apology
uh moved council ladlow seconded
councillor sophomore i'll put that
motion order some favor
hi against thank you that's passed
right go to the interest register i have
not been notified of any changes
now we'll go to the
receiving and confirming the minutes of
the
infrastructure services meeting february
2
21. if someone moved that place
thank you councillor crackit seconded
council lewis i'll put that all those in
favor
hi against
we'll go now to the minutes of the
extraordinary
infrastructure services committee held
16 february 2021
someone move councillor crackers
seconded councillor skilt
i'll put that all in favor hi
hence that is carried now that brings us
to the first major item which is the
housing rental fees consultation report
and to speak to that we have
heather and rihanna welcome
i will have heather speak first and then
[Music]
rihanna
uh thank you mr chair uh councillors
um just in regards to the housing
consultation
um which has taken place over a few
uh weeks um the
consultation was in regards to the
increased
proposed increased rental for our
housing tenants
which was put through the infrastructure
committee on the 16th of november where
it was
agreed that an increase of 35
would be put out to consultation to our
tenants
that consultation process has taken
place
and um rihanna would you like to speak
[Music]
thank you chair counselor so i'll just
touch briefly on a few of the points
in my report that cover the consultation
process for this
issue so as heather says the
consultation was undertaken with tenants
those directly affected by the issue in
line with the significance
and engagement policy we also went
beyond that to ask for submissions from
housing providers
so you'll be aware that um you heard
this matter um
on the 16th of february and
we received 25 submissions in total
that included some informal comments
given to the housing officer which we
also put forward to you and are included
in the appendix
you heard from six submitters on the day
so this report summarizes the issues
that the tenants raised
in their submissions as well as the
submissions from organizations with a
hat
an interest in housing so i won't speak
to all those issues
but i will just touch briefly on those
issues that counselors asked specific
questions about and asked for
information to be provided
so the first of those was the question
of the level of the accommodation
supplements so just to clarify
that because council is not a registered
housing provider
the level of accommodation supplement
that's available
each week is of a different level than
some of the submissions from tenants
we've had this information confirmed
from work and income and that's provided
here in this report
and the housing officer has learned that
some tenants have been informed
following the hearings by working income
that are actually eligible for more
support than they were receiving
on the issue of whether council itself
can become a registered community
housing provider
again we've just provided the clarity on
that information that council cannot
itself
be a registered community housing
provider it could sell the assets
to another organization which could be
a council-controlled organization but it
cannot itself be
a registered housing provider council
commissioned a report in 2017
which looked at the service delivery for
housing care and this
issue was considered council did not
take the option at that time
and has received feedback including
through the verbal submissions at this
hearings
that tenants prefer that council remains
the landlord
and obviously that does impact on the
accommodation supplement
issue raised above um thirdly in
relation to the issue that was raised by
one of the submitters
that the austin lee units were
gifted to council we've just gone back
through the records
and provided that information included
in the report
about how that transfer of those assets
came to be
in terms of being in exchange for
roading costs
so it was not a gift as such
finally the last question was around
different options for implementation
of the rental increase and i'll just let
heather speak
to these three options that we've
provided in this report
but just to clarify that the first
option
um is the original option that was
chosen by council in november and that
is why it remains the remain
recommended option here for you to
consider
and i'll just clarify now that if
council was to consider option three
that does
include um an option to consider
uh some funding from general rates this
would actually then be out
out of line with the activity plan and
would require
general public consultation so i'll just
flag that now at this point
so yes as random has advised we
are the three options are to stay with
the recommended option of a 35
increase and the statistics that we've
proposed there
um i do acknowledge there is an error in
the
third line on each of the proposed fee
structure
um that the one bedroom unit with a
carport
the current rate should read a maximum
of 146
please note these are the maximum rates
these are not the actual rates charged
and therefore the 2021 proposed fee
would go up to 197 and
accordingly the other three options
would have uh changes to them as well
so um the 35
increase would allow council to
uh complete the healthy home standards
required
um and also complete two
new units and replace three and a half
units per year
which gives us an asset replacement um
cycle of 61 years on option one
this is fully funded from rental income
and no rates income
required the proposal under proposed
option
two um is
basically effectively spreading that 35
increase over two years um it means the
program would be slightly longer
and we would replacing
be replacing 3.4 units per year
is advised option three
proposes a rates
input and as randon said that would
require a separate consultation if
council were to choose that option
um and it would
uh mean that uh
there would be approximately 59 000 a
year
in rate subsidy required for that
um council
um oh sorry i am um still recommending
that option one be the preferred option
for this
um the last item on the um
on the report is in regards to the
housing policy and
um it is our recommendation that we do
develop a policy for housing units um we
just have a procedure at this point in
time
and so as part of that would
be developed through the next rtp
process
um so that just brings me to the
recommendations
so um it have been so if i just go
through the recommendations on the
screen
so um the recommendations are that the
reports be received
um that the submissions were received
we are recommending that council retain
ownership and not
sell the units to an arms length
organisation
and therefore council would not become a
community housing provider
recommendation five has been when ocean
red
it shows uh option one that the rental
rates would be increased by 35 percent
from one july
21 that's just clarifying that and the
recommendation for you
uh recommendation six is development of
a housing policy and
i would also like to add a new
recommendation
um acknowledging the error and amending
line
three in each of the options
um showing that the actual maximum rate
is up to 146 dollars
um and um before the
amended rates in the 2021 22 years
uh 35 and 35 percent an option one
sorry um any question okay
right so the way we're going to work
this is um i'm going to open it up now
for questions
of both rhiannon and heather and then
i'm going to
open it up for debate but uh so question
time this is purely does
simply clarify points counselor clark
yes uh thank you
um you might be able to help me just
with some some things i just need to
clarify
um it seems to me when i did this
exercise myself online just to sort of
get a feel for
what our tenants might be facing i went
on to the wins
website and put my own details in and
didn't put any income source with it so
i just put my age in fact i was on
national super
when i got part way down i got to a bit
of a stumbling block and it sort of
asked me who is the current landlord
and i naturally thought that maybe the
current landlord
or an icc flat would be a community
housing provider
and so i put that in and that made a
huge difference because i didn't
actually get any
accommodation supplement because the
impact of that i've now found by going
to winds
is that it brings you into a different
category when you're in that
classification
so when i went back and did the excise
of
um just putting in
icc as a private landlord
winds now tell me that brings um
accommodation supplement into play
and so they've said to me just broadly
without getting down to specific clients
because there are some criteria about
income levels
so if you earn up to about 520 a week
uh you can still get the accommodation
supplement beyond that it drops back
and the assets that they refer to is not
the fact that you might own a house but
if you've got cash assets in a bank or
kiwisaver assets up to what 8100 you're
still exempt
beyond that it starts to weight
backwards so i'm picking that most of
our clients wouldn't have substantial
amounts in all of those two categories
um and so what they said is the general
formula they use as if
if the rent goes up by x amount of
dollars
roughly speaking 70 percent of that they
call it
0.70 will be paid by the accommodation
supplement and the other
30 or 0.3 it's the tenant
when i do some basic figures around that
it seems to me that
when we look at option two um and you
and i factor in
the accommodation supplement the range
of increases that our clients or tenants
are likely to get is somewhere between
six or seven or eight dollars
is that your take yes that is great yes
um and the other issue i guess was the
issue that we had
put forward by the one of the groups on
behalf of
our tenants or speaking to about this
registration issue
and my understanding if you could just
clarify that again is that
we can't be a registered provider which
if we were a registered provider the
benefit of that is that the rents get
capped at 25
of personal income so to be reasoned we
would have to sell it
current flats we've got to an
independent body which needs to be at
arm's length away from the organization
we can't just set up a trust and
have counsellors as trustees is that
your take as well yes that's correct
current legislation does not allow
councils
as such to become a registered community
provider
uh they can sell their units to an
arms length organisation which
could be uh council could be a
shareholder of
and and just as a final question here
that um you've probably had the same
advice that i've had so i just want to
clarify this the advice i got from wins
from a supervisor there was the major
point that might be triggering people's
unease about the accommodation
supplement is the fact that they haven't
put in
private landlord so um the public
perception is that council our community
housing provider
however we're not a registered community
housing provider
and so when it asks you their question
and they're the
ones are assuming that that's a
registered
housing provider so we are provided
a private provider as far as that goes
thank you okay councillor lewis
at least once
we haven't had a rent increase over the
past two years now
okay any other questions for heather
rhiannon
okay what i'm gonna do is um
i'm gonna hear from all counsellors
today so i'm gonna start
when i start this with alex and work
around the table but first i just need
to check with
two councillors one council lush just
because you weren't here
for the submissions and uh just
wondering have you
have you read uh are you are you
comfortable with the information you've
read about the submissions
to to partake in this that's a bit of a
tough yeah okay
thank you and councillor abbott you were
not at
their at submissions so just asking you
are you comfortable
with the information you have i'm glad
you asked
that i was going to seek clarification
and i am comfortable
okay thank you for that right um
okay i'm gonna and now start with i'm
gonna work around the table
starting with counselor cracker um thank
you mr chair
um i think that from the consultation
uh around this particular issue i think
it was really clear we had a really
clear steer from our community
that they want us to provide social
housing but they don't
or they didn't feel it was fair for us
to subsidize it
um and because in doing that you're only
subsidizing a portion of the populace or
a portion of our
our populists that actually live in our
social housing when across the board
um there are a lot of people in our city
that are in hardship
and to just subsidise just part of it
under right rates
me just didn't seem fair um and to the
wider
community i believe as well and that we
had a very clear steer from our
consultation that said that they clearly
want us to continue to provide it but
they don't want us to
fund it out of the general rate um
i think it's also extremely promising or
um
forward thinking that we're actually
making sure that we are putting things
into place now so we adhere to those
healthy home standards
it's really important that as a social
housing social housing provider that we
are providing quality homes
and keeping our stock at under 65 years
um canceling all of the information and
now knowing what we do
with uh the fact that we're not a social
how sorry a community housing provider
that our people can access that
accommodation supplement
at a
considerably drops the amount that their
increase will go up by
and to around that eight to ten dollar
mark
and option two i'm comfortable with with
voting for it and going forward
okay thank you council correct council
lewis thank you mr chair i think council
cracker has said it
very eloquently and i didn't go along
with that the effect of the rent hasn't
have not gone up in the last two years
but superannuation has
i think the the eight dollars
is mitigated by the increases in the
superiority
as council credit says similar health
homes aspects that we have good
landlords
to make sure that those regulations are
combined with
and i would like to make sure that any
tenants
whichever way we vote tenants are helped
to apply for the
accommodation supplements but certainly
some were
either confused or not given the correct
advice before
when they submitted a lot of them
a lot of submissions were of the opinion
that we're not entitled
to that supplement they've got it from
other sources
not just their own section but i think
we need to have some input
to help them make sure okay
thank you counselors your worship yes
thank you yeah um can you just grab one
of two microphones
thank you
they'll have to excuse me cracking away
like an old
chainsaw but um i've
this came into contact with housing when
it was
considered government prerogative to
build as many possible possibilities as
you can
and have a wide range of available
housing
there was strings attached admittedly
like
you couldn't on sell it
unless it was to sell to buy other
housing
but it was aimed at stimulating
the growth of housing in the city
then we had the state housing
era and because my dad had been a
pilot in the fleet air arm when i got
back to new zealand
uh my widowed mum and young brother
got a state house immediately because
they wanted to show
support for people who had served
overseas
and so you were bumped to the top of the
list and it was a long list at that time
with all the
baby boomers and then of course in
more recent times we had the ty smelter
project
and if you go into certain areas of the
city
you'll find a mess produced not pretty
but those state houses and these
ty houses did the job
and it gave a morale boosters are those
who are struggling and the perception i
think
with such a large increase
will be that we're heartless and
aren't prepared to support the those who
are struggling in our city
thank you thank you worship councillor
clark
yeah thank you um well i've already seen
quite a bit already but um
i'm i'm in favor of option two because
it staggers it over two years and the
benefits
or lack of benefits between option one
and option two are quite minimal
um my assessment is that given the
information
up there that we got that we've got some
capping going on up to 146 dollars
then my assessment is that the uh the
flow on effect of the tenants will be
somewhere around the
nine to ten dollars a week right under
option one
and under option two somewhere between
four and a half
4.50 and five dollars per week under
option two
i think that's quite a minor increase
given that we haven't had one for two
years
um and the um
results that i've seen do not factor in
that the government
has announced a 3.1 percent increase to
uh all benefits uh as of the 1st of
april this year
and so if you look at a person that
might be on a couple that might be on
joint
national super that 3 or three point one
percent
probably close to about nineteen dollars
a week i know it doesn't just cover
accommodation it covers food and living
costs as well
but part of it is the living cost of
what you might be paying in rent so
couple that with the access to the
accommodation supplement i'm definitely
in favor of option two
thank you for that counselor skill after
you cheer
if one looked at the business model
that's been presented a big thank you to
heather ryan for the information that's
been given it's incredibly
detailed if you look at the business
model
it's the right model model uh option one
is the right model
in my opinion um because it continues on
and we we
look to replacement and we look to
improvement going forward so that's
the business model i guess the
compelling argument for me
is when we had the submitters and the
stories they told
and i think one thing as a council we
have a responsibility
for our right power and in particular
our people
are our most important asset that we
have it's our people
there were some exceptionally compelling
stories here
some councils have mentioned that the
there hasn't been a rate increase over
the last two years
and we've had a superannuation which is
true but every other part of society has
increased also
every other battle has increased
so we're very comfortable about building
a cbd
we're very comfortable about our bricks
and mortar i just remind you all
we need to look after it some of those
folks
in this room are in very unfortunate
situations
so i would be in favor of option two at
this point
thank you councillor councillor
thank you cheer um especially i think we
just need to clarify that
it's not social housing that we're
providing the housing was built
as housing for the elderly uh there was
a period where we had
um sufficient vacancies to take in
people under other circumstances
and and some of that has become legacy
tendencies but
it's actually established as elderly
housing and i think there is a
difference
because there and there was
traditionally
a position that council filled whereas
the the wider responsibility of social
housing and i don't decry the need for
social housing at all but it's actually
the responsibility of central government
so it's something i think we need to
keep in mind
um it's been really useful since
uh some powerful submissions to hear
uh clarification around our
classification as a landlord that that
we're private
and i think it's it's easy to understand
why people either
themselves or under advice may have
thought that we were a community
uh provider and and that's a game
changer for
many of our submitters because uh it
seems they do qualify for a supplement
and that raises other questions like you
know should it be back paid
um but that's not that's not for this
council
uh to to deal with um
i'm torn between options one and two
there's there's a nominal difference i
think of 3.4 and 3.5
units per year being replaced between
the two and option two obviously looks
at the staging and when we heard from
the submitters
um i think they were accepting
of the fact that an increase in in
rental
is something that would happen but that
they had asked that it
that it be staged so i just i mean i'm
going through a process where i'm still
working this out in my mind and i'll
wait till i've finished hearing from
from everybody else
we do have a responsibility and we have
a responsibility not only to the tenants
but the other rate payers so part of our
current policy
is that the the housing rental is not
supported by the general rate
uh and the general rate is paid by the
person that i like to refer to as the
little old lady living in pomona street
in a one-bedroom unit wondering whether
or not she's going to turn the heating
on
so as soon as you start to subsidize
uh the housing rental from the general
rate you're asking someone who's
potentially in a similar position to to
support it as well and there's a part of
me
that just struggles with that i think
it'll be interesting to see when we go
through a review and develop a housing
policy
um that's a discussion that'll come up
and
we'll hear from people at that time at
the moment uh an
increase i i think is inevitable 35
percent is
is an amount as a percentage that tends
to
capture your attention but when you
weighed against a couple of points one
uh that the housing uh the accommodation
supplement does
apply in many cases two that there is an
increase
in the benefit uh coming up
and three as a dollar amount that's
actually
quite small and and affordable and
actually
it is worth council bearing in mind that
the rental that is paid for
uh cities housing rental is well below
the existing market standard
so i'm leaning towards option one i'm
open to entertaining option two but
still interested to hear what others
have to say
thank you thank you council hello
councillor
thank you mr chia um
we were one of those councils who were
brave enough
several years ago to stay in housing
when others exited
in another political life i disagreed
with many of those councils who did
exit my my feeling is still
that councils have a very definite role
in the area of housing
we should not exit um
and the return of the four well-beings i
think cements
why local bodies do have a role in the
in the housing area
um we should be
landlords for the elderly and disabled
which was the original
intention um as councillor ludlow
pointed out there were some
lean years when we had faces and other
renters did come in but
largely we have been a landlord
in some cases of last resort for elderly
and disabled and we should
remain in that role local government
definitely has a role in it
and we should be good landlords which is
what
this whole paper and the issues put
forward and
that we are going to put in the heat
pumps that we are looking at other ways
to improve our units
and that we are thinking about the
future of building
slightly larger in some cases
better more up-to-date units
and i think that that is a very good
plan i'm very pleased that the
accommodation supplement information has
been fully clarified
i did try to say during the submissions
that i believe there had been
some unfortunately inaccurate
information given
um and that it was largely based
on the confusion over which category of
landlord council fell into so i'm really
pleased that's been clarified
i think that will ease the mind of some
of the submitters
[Music]
but two things i suppose in the end way
with me
[Music]
those who submitted overall did have
compelling stories
and they did ask very politely
for um some staging
the information we now have shows that
in fact there is not
such a large difference between option
one and option two
um that that i feel we still
will be able to do that rebuilding and
that improving of the units
and that we are not going to be
a significant number of years further
back
in increasing our housing stock
so my feeling at the moment is that i'm
comfortable to go with option two if the
council decision is to go with option
one i'm also
comfortable to support the majority of
council
but my leaning is towards options thank
you councillor sopa councillor kit
thank you chairman just carrying on from
what uh councillor crackit
made reference to like there are over 10
000 people in our community currently
receiving the pension of that number 40
percent rely solely
on the pension to live it's over 4 000
people in their community
and they have a sad struggle week after
week and during winter months a
large number of them stay in bed until
after lunch
just to quit keep warm and some also
struggle to pay for food
i say yes we are definitely heading in
the right direction
but is it fair to ask our current
tenants to pay extra
so that in their weekly rental so we can
replace
the units for the future is that fair
i'm just not sure
i do realize the subsidy um
all about the subsidies now thank you to
council nobody clark
uh emailing that to us a couple of weeks
ago
but i'm still not sure if we should be
asking our current tenants
to pay that little bit extra
to upgrade the units for the future
um rather than that
putting the rentals up can we obtain
money from from the likes of holdco
to take the burden off
no it's it's the same as the
same as taking a the same thing
holco is a right as a dividend bearing
organization to the rape
thank you for that clarification um i am
slightly uncomfortable
with option one
more comfortable with option two
i'll just let the debate roll on and see
what happens okay
all right counselor lush welcome to your
first
infrastructure meeting yeah thank you
chair um look very much in favor of the
council
having housing very much in favor of the
council providing warm housing i'm
surprised it hasn't got the heat pumps
and things like that i think the optics
are bad
we've got the new mall going and we've
got cold housing um
so i'm absolutely in favor of heat pumps
going i think
as a landlord we need to look like we
care about our tenants
to um to propose a 35 pay
uh rate increase weeks before christmas
i think was
not the measure of a good landlord um so
that concerns me
um i'm in favor of option two i think
that is the fairest way to go
um i also think with heat pumps i think
some provision needs to be made
from my experience of elderly people
with heat pumps i have trouble using
them
in the first couple of months even years
the bills can be very very high
i'd like to see some sort of provision
in there so in fact
the people can be trained properly with
them because i think particularly for
elderly people
they require a bit of upskilling to use
them efficiently but yeah look i'm very
much in favor of them having um
warm housing particularly for people in
bluff there's not a lot of other
rental accommodations for elderly people
there i think it's very very important i
think the right thing has been done
i just think that the way it was handled
in terms of optics looks bad for the
council
and i think as we've seen from these
discussions today in fact the rent
increase is minimal and it probably
could have been handled differently
thank you council now sure i'm going to
go
to the lads on zoom starting in
alphabetical order
counselor thank you for that can you
hear me
yeah yep okay great okay um i'm
an advocate of option two um and
i agree with darren that we are not
community housing we are elderly housing
that's
how it was instigated um somebody
mentioned that the super is going up
again thankfully
in my case um and
social responsibility is the thing that
we're in here for
i believe that the council does have a
social responsibility to the elderly
um agree with um councillor lush that
there has to be an educational program
going ahead if we're going to install
heat pumps i'm pretty sure there are
heat pumps
in some of the units currently um
the two years is only slightly longer it
goes from 63 to 65 i think
and you're still replacing the 3.4 units
rather than the three units under option
one
so seven to eight dollars on the
accommodation allowance we're all
familiar now with that
and uh we should encourage our students
to take that up
and i think education is prime education
has brought so i'm with option two the
only other point i wanted to ask and
it's a sort of guidance from youtube um
are we making any reference to uh the
email that we got from mr tribe
sorry there's nothing on the agenda here
right should there have been no no the
agenda has been prepared
and there is nothing here i was of the
understanding that he was going to make
representation
now there's nothing in public forum okay
thank you for that just want to clarify
now we join councillor arnold
uh good afternoon everybody if you can
hear me clearly
good um well i'd like to congratulate
the staff on the report i think it's a
good report and counselor clark on the
work he's done as well
behind the scenes um i believe in the
concept that
of the elderly housing and increasing
air stocks over a period of time
the differences between 61 and 63 years
61
for the for option 163 years for option
two
certainly steers me towards option two
and with
the increases that we are now aware of
that clark
has brought to our attention um
is very negligible it's not a it's not a
huge amount in my view
we do need to look towards upgrading
these they do need all to be upgraded as
much as they can
but i'd like to see us over a period of
time actually increase their
air stock you know over a long period of
time i'm talking about so i
um support option two and i think
education
of tenants for using new equipment is a
good idea as well
option two from me thank you thank you
councillor arnold um
right um my my take on this is that the
35
percent increases it's playing rapid
catch-up
and it may be justified as councillors
skilled
but in the economic look at this but
to me uh 35 is uh
is not an option after listening to the
submissions um
i'm in favor of option two and uh also
the education of heat pumps is a
critical thing
because they are a unit that operates
best
when left on and not used as a heater
so that education is quite critical so
um right thank you for everyone
who are participating now i'm going to
take these recommendations
in basically three blocks
and they will be uh one
through two four okay
and then i'm going to take five on its
own
and then finish off with six so
can i have someone move up uh
recommendations one
two to four uh we'll
councillor scott seconded councillors
hoper i'm going to put those motions all
in favor
all right against thank you
now i'm going to move to option uh sorry
to
recommendation 5 which applies to which
option
we go for here so
counselor so i'll move
resolution number five
second
and obviously um we have to alter the
percent option too but
in option two so that actually drags
across a new
um staging up since for the two years
so in doing this
okay look can we just um
yeah just adjourn for a minute while we
get this wording right it's going to pop
up on the screen
and so everyone knows
okay
this
hey
so we don't get a chance to talk anymore
oh no
um
um
in the meeting please
you'll note um
new the new recommendation five
and uh this specifically says
there's two years you'll note in the
literature
it says two or more uh are you happy
counselor say for
two years okay thank you
right the signature was counselor skill
uh moved so far all right
obviously i think we have that stop it
yep
that's right okay so what i'm going to
do now is i'm going to
put that motion all those in favor
please say hi
against that motion is passed
for recommendation 5. now we go to
recommendation six
i have someone please move that do you
want recommendation section seven chair
oh we got a seven there too yes okay six
and seven move both ways
thank you councillor sopa sorry council
ludlow secondary council of sofa
what the motion was in favor hi against
thank you that is carried and
that is that done thank you very much
thank you for your time with that one
we're going to move on now
to the report on the
bluff ramp updates
and we have steve speaking to that
we have leslie sorry sorry
leslie welcome
right was yours um so this is the report
to update you
on the um bluff boat ramp and the
proposed user fees for the boat ramp
through the ltp and we have
just recently in the last week or so
approved with jacob's consulting
the detailed design package and we'll be
looking for that in the next 16 to 20
weeks
to come back and build a tender package
for this project so um
if they're that's pretty much
okay thanks this is an update and the
report is to be received so
i'm gonna open up for questions anyone
anyone got questions yes counselor
thanks cheer
uh look was there any indication of of
how long it's likely to be until we get
some clarification
around the funding of the hull wash
no i haven't received any commitment to
that
thank you hello
are you worship yes thank you mr pearce
there
um any indication as to that money being
received as a result of
uh land that was taken off
so that settlement has been established
with es and sec environment southland
and south
and that is part of the package on that
table of the second page of the report
where there they have funded 400 and 300
respectively towards the
renewal of the boatman
um yeah just a little bit of the report
there obviously and i just
was looking at the the different models
that you've used
from uh other places things and i just
noticed that you didn't actually mention
any prices that they actually charge for
those services you've got their
proposed charges below it but not theirs
i just can't see them
the other thing is if you've got any
projected cash flow s
you know potential cash flow uh
projections going forward
with the new based on those charges that
you're suggesting
so we did do a whole um
recce on what what both charges are used
on throughout all those models
our um fee isn't top of those
and not the bottom either it's somewhere
in the middle of
what other boat ramps charge and
we can't do a cash projection that is
really thorough because we only have
about three months worth of data of
boat ramp use usage so to extrapolate
that i would could would be assuming a
lot
to do with seasons et cetera et cetera
so
does that answer no not really because i
mean
you know when you're doing a business
model to speak and get out of
that you know rejected cash right not
might not necessarily be what it
becomes but it gives us a wee bit of an
idea as to
the amount of money that's being spent
is um going to be you know
probably uh i i guess uh recollected
over a period a number of years or
something
we just don't have any idea of that
looking at the report vessel
okay we are going to have council that
alone council itself
thanks cheer just following on from the
comment from councillor and we can't
expect staff to do magic
um she explained that she's only got
three months worth of data
that doesn't take into account seasonal
um
changes and and some relax and
reluctance to extrapolate i know we'd
like to have
a model but it's it's just it's not
available
um we've we've got some fees suggested
um i'm comfortable with them uh they go
out for consultation i guess
with with the long-term plan um
it'll be interesting to get feedback
because obviously people are used to not
paying fees
um and yet they're getting quite a
service and and quite a few of those
users
uh uh heavy commercial as well
by councillor sopa thanks mr leslie i
was just going to ask about the clean
hull
facilities where you've got the um
the fact that es had made an earlier
commitment to incorporating the clean
health facilities and
covered the funding was no longer
available we expect you'll be picked up
again
just for clarification we're still
talking to es about that possibility
absolutely and the project has um left
area within
the scope of the project for that
facility to be developed at a later
stage
we are definitely hoping that that can
be the case
right yep
okay council louis thank you mr chair
leslie obviously the bluff
ramp has come up many times with the
bluff community board and bluff 2024
so the first attempt will be community
buy-in
the likes of mary less et cetera and
people within the community seeing other
people with permits
and having chat to them about permits we
will also have a camera from the area
and the cash will be able to be paid
either at the bluff um service center or
online
um if that practice doesn't
work we're going to have to review it as
we go but we believe that there will be
a good buy-in from the community on this
very thank you very much okay
look a couple of questions from me
leslie um
the first one i'm going to start off
with uh swimming
now moving forward with the uh with the
ramp and the
new what's going to happen there because
we've got a
health and safety issue straight up with
these boats so
so as the report does detail there on
the last page that um
there is obviously a conflict between
marine movements and
uh swimming and launching and launching
boats
and we'll review that as we go as well
if there's additional measures required
once the boat ramp is developed we will
we will
talk to the community and about
alternate potential swimming spots as
well
but we would be recommending that we try
to
have swimmers avoid this area with the
boat movement
okay the other question i have is um
when you look at the aerial shot of um
of the boat ram where where would the
hull washing
um go it's quite confined for space
so the current car park for the
museum would be reduced
and it will be on the south end of that
car park
in that area there okay and the other is
more of a statement actually and it's
it's quite fortuitous that if
if you go to council maps on our website
and you
zoom in on the boat ramp a particular
day the satellite was flying over
captures 23 vehicles and
rather large trailers parked all around
the area
there's quite a sight to see that's
captured on that day so
it just shows how busy this is the whole
every parking area available was taken
up
down the side of the roads everything
it's quite amazing actually
so if you need to know about the use of
it it
it sums it up quite well right so the
the recommendation is the poor report be
received
is there any more discussion no okay
because someone please move that this be
received
counselor skill second council lewis
demotion
those in favor against
right that is all we before we finish
though we do
have an update on
three waters um erin
yes so you will have seen um a process
that we've been going through around
submitting to central government's water
services
bill uh the otago southland
group that have come together to
collaborate around
water reform decided that we would
prepare a joint
submission and essentially go around to
each council get their thoughts on on
the key areas that were common across us
and provide that government on behalf of
all of us
i submitted that or forwarded that
around to
everybody late last week um essentially
this is just an opportunity
to formalize the fact that icc have
provided that position and asked
right do you have any questions for
aaron
no you need to hear
back from everybody
[Music]
thank you
hopefully everyone gets back to you
right
um was that
yep
all right make sense right
um i'm gonna move into public excluded
now um with the exception of uh
mr grant mr mckenzie but uh
we will be stopping live streaming
so those doing the live streaming
hearing me would you like a second
yes can i please i've moved that i have
someone seen that
counseling
thank you thank you members of the
you